all right let's get into audience
questions for the week some interesting
ones starting with Eric Eric says hey
David when people say no homo does that
go under the category of homophobic slur
so if you haven't heard this phrase
before when people say no homo it's a
sort of slang that you would say at the
end of a sentence to make clear that
whatever you said before was not said in
a way to imply homosexuality
homoeroticism attraction to other men
it's meant to sort of clarify that you
are not to be thought of as making a gay
double entendre of any kind all right
so imagine that you said it's a
good-looking guy you know then this
actor is a good-looking guy no homo so
what you're saying is I'm recognizing
the attractiveness of another man but I
don't mean that in a gay way that's a
really nice-looking shawl sweater no
homo I just I I think it's a good
fashion statement but I'm not saying I'm
attracted to you so the whole point of
this is that it's part of displaying
masculinity and when young men used the
phrase it's basically saying I need to
reaffirm my gender and my sexuality my
sexual orientation because I don't want
it to be misinterpreted and this sort of
relates to the story we did earlier this
week about Donald Trump and Jordan
Peterson types appealing to those who
are often insecure about their
masculinity we did a story about that
earlier this week I genuinely can't
think of any situation I've been in
where I compliment another man's haircut
or their clothing or say that such and
such as a handsome guy I've never felt
the need to clarify that I mean it
merely in a non homosexual way like
there were no reasons why I would feel
the need to reaffirm my heterosexuality
so I wouldn't call it a slur per se and
there are actually some uses of this
that you could argue are challenging the
status quo right so you could say
something that might in popular culture
be thought of as romantic or sexual in
some way but by saying no homo you might
merely be pointing out I'm able to say
this and it's not a romantic thing it's
not a sexual thing so you might even be
able to find isolated cases where it's
sort of challenging the status quo but
in the end it's about context and it's
about intent so I don't think that we
benefit in any way from saying simply no
homo is a homophobic slur it is often
used to convince others of your
masculinity by pointing out that you're
not saying something that should be
interpreted or misinterpreted in a
homoerotic or gay way of any kind but if
we didn't have circumstances where
people felt the need to reassert that
constantly it probably would be an
irrelevant phrase I don't use it and
again I've never felt the need to assert
my credentials as a heterosexual male
because I don't feel as though listen
lots of people think I'm gay based on
the show that I do I defend gay rights
on the program I just don't care right
in the end I don't even really care if
people attribute homosexuality to me
it's sort of more their thing than mine
and it's never a phrase that I felt the
need to use in some cases it is
definitely homophobic but I would not
say that it is objectively a homophobic
slur in all cases